si mme françois s'il table à cartes
c'est caroline ma femme qui avait acheté
le voyage sur internet
elle m'a quitté le mode après sélection
pleine dépression depuis six mois
ah oui ouais
gabriel m'a dit que tu étais un
excellent membre et voilà la merveille
est détachable
je vais essayer 4e mandat parts aux
quatre coins de l'hexagone
la quête comme d'enseignants d un an
prenez la première sans trop savoir
manuel mais ça va je plaisante
d'après emmanuel
la brosse en poils de sanglier rien
alors je vends pas des brosses à dents
ici et les gens qui viennent prendre de
l'essence ils n'ont pas des dents bon je
vous jure que ça nous intéresse pas ça
c'est mon école c'est là que j'ai connu
ou john tu l'aurais vu à 18 ans suivant
ses vacances et ça te plairait que je
peux front brosse à dents vous faites
quoi dans la boîte beaucoup de la vente
les colporteurs colporteurs il parlait
de musiciens ne dis pas que je
connaissais pas colporteurs calculant
coup gagnant pourrait fermer à kaunas
vous avez connu la solitude ou la vraie
maman à socialement
c'est ça que j'aime bien chez toi tu me
dis-je pas
passe notre vie à éviter les contacts
avec les autres
je frôle
je crois toi mais j'ai vite
j'ai réalisé à ce moment que si je
mourais subitement d'une crise cardiaque
se ne bouleverserait pas grand cas pas
l'air très bien votre ami en fait il a
des remords mais pas du tout jeune et en
pleine discussion il est battu mais bien
monsieur quoique sans rapport avec ce
que je racontais que ça existe un être
ennuyeux à mourir
oui vous savez pas de nulle part son
expression